we got to get into loose for a little
bit I was at a fan convention in Rome I
was in the minibus on the way back from
the convention to the hotel we were
staying at and I got a call from our
showrunner saying that fox had just
canceled the show I was crushed I like I
was so like I was thrown I just didn't I
I didn't expect it to happen and I found
out that fox still hadn't announced that
they were going had canceled it yet so
we knew but no one else knew then
someone tipped me off I'm not going to
say who but someone tipped me off that
fox had planned to kind of bury the news
of the cancellation by announcing
something else at the same time or there
a new show replacing Lucifer yeah and
any yeah yeah all of that and I was you
know I had a lot of emotion going on a
lot of these things and I decided that I
would take it upon myself to tweet that
I had found out the show had been
cancelled and I was absolutely gutted
and I'm sorry to everyone and I did that
good move were they pissed I don't
care